[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en très mauvais état doit subir une
restauration conséquente la difficulté
c'était de retrouver en fait une
cohérence entre deux structures qui qui
coexistent dans cette dans cette maison
une structure en bois et une structure
en maçonnerie la structure en bois a
subi des déformations
considérables a pu les absorber ce que
ne pouvait pas faire la maçonnerie en
brique les travaux devraient s'achever
courant 2023 mais la finalité de
l'opération reste à trouver notre
préoccupation première c'était de la
sauver et d'éviter qu'elle ne tombe elle
était arrivée à un stade vous seriez
venu il y a une quinzaine de jours de ça
vous aviez un énorme trou ici à la place
de la maison aujourd'hui on a
reconstitué toute la charpente en bois
ce qui était ce qui est quand même une
gageure avec du bois neuf qui ne doit
avoir que quelques centaines d'années et
donc notre priorité c'était de s'assurer
que cette maison nous survive et survive
aux générations à venir
en attendant l'urgence est de consolider
la toiture avec la pose d'une nouvelle
charpente
une collecte est en cours sur le site de
la Fondation du Patrimoine une
association d'utilités publiques pour
restaurer la maison des Alix elle a déjà
donné 450
000 euros par le biais du Loto du
patrimoine sur un budget total estimé un
million deux
on voit passer à certains nombres de
projets au niveau de la délégation
régionale et on va soutenir des projets
qui nous paraissent les plus
intéressants en respectant certaines
normes de critères à la fois le l'état
de ruine c'était le cas de la maison des
alliés c'est l'intérêt patrimonial bien
entendu et puis la particularité essayer
de sortir un petit peu des des sentiers
battus où on voit souvent des églises
enfin du patrimoine religieux ou des
châteaux ici c'était une maison de ville
donc c'était intéressant
la Fondation du Patrimoine est une
véritable bouée de sauvetage pour de
nombreuses petites villes en France qui
ne savent plus comment gérer leur trésor
du passé devenu bien encombrant
Blois ville d'art et d'histoire possède
de nombreux monuments classés ou
inscrits et pas des moindres comme le
château ou la maison de la magie
au niveau de la sphère on va être un peu
plus couvrant que le anciens aujourd'hui
qui étaient en place c'est-à-dire que
les moins longs vont être moins
apparents donc ça ça a été vu avec
l'architecte des bâtiments de France
aussi on a l'exemple qu'on a fait de
l'autre côté au sud qui est fini on va
reproduire exactement la même chose avec
la même formulation d'accord
et là nous sommes tranquille pour au
moins 100 ans
je fais ça j'espère je ne sais plus
merde dans ce sens
ou de l'opération plus de 3 millions
d'euros dont 565 000 pour la ville qui
consacre par ailleurs près de 10% de son
budget d'investissement à la
restauration et à l'entretien de son
patrimoine historique alors le
diagnostic que nous avions commandé à
nos services et avec une entreprise
spécialisée démontré qu'il fallait
intervenir de façon rapide notamment sur
le bâti avec des éléments qui
potentiellement pouvaient être en
situation fragilité un choix financier
de plus en plus compliqué pour les
communes
alors là on est dans un contexte un peu
particulier avec la crise actuelle les
budgets des villes sont un peu plus
serrées et on sent que le marché a
tendance à se ralentir un petit peu
la ville de Blois avec un taux de
pauvreté au-dessus de la moyenne c'est
tout de même séparé de certains de ces
monuments elle devra sans doute se
résoudre à le faire pour une ancienne
graine trie dont il subsiste seulement
les murs au grand dames dérivera
ce sont des choix politiques moi je ne
suis pas je ne suis pas Monsieur le
Maire de Blois je dis simplement que ce
sont des choix politiques simplement et
que ce bâtiment là absolument toute sa
place dans le patrimoine bléois qu'il
soit réhabiliter qu'il soit protégé
mais pour le maire ce bâtiment est trop
dégradé pour l'ouvrir au public nous
n'avons pas mis de priorité sur ce ce
patrimoine qui est une ruine et donc
nous n'excluons pas en effet la vente il
y a aussi l'intérêt d'avoir le secteur
privé qui peut puisque le bâtiment est
classé devra respecter des prérogatives
de la Direction Jeunesse et faire
culturelle de l'architecte des bâtiments
de France donc c'est aussi l'opportunité
en France comme ailleurs de pouvoir
avoir aussi le secteur privé qui
intervient sur la rénovation la
préservation d'un certain patrimoine
c'est le cas par exemple à Blois avec
l'Hôtel-Dieu
la graine sera peut-être bien tôt la
propriété d'un promoteur immobilier qui
installera des logements un scandale
plutôt une opération courante pour la
drague la Direction Régionale des
Affaires Culturelles
si une ville décide de vendre un
promoteur immobilier il peut évidemment
en faire l'usage qu'il souhaitera à
condition de respecter toutes les
caractéristiques attachées au monument
et donc il ne pourra pas modifier et à
plus forte raison détruire toutes les
parties qui sont protégées en qualité de
monuments historique certains ne sont
pas de cet avis c'est le cas de Didier
Rickert le médiatique rédacteur en chef
de La Tribune de l'Art et Hart dans
défenseur du patrimoine les villes qui
se séparent de leur monument historique
en général le font pour de très
mauvaises raisons soit parce qu'il
considère que ça coûte trop cher soit
considère que c'est un mauvais état et
donc il préfère laisser à d'autres le
soin de les restaurer soit il
s'intéresse complètement pas enfin en
général ça prouve quand ils vendent des
monuments qui n'ont pas du tout la
conscience patrimoniale qu'il devrait
avoir en tant que mère de deux villes et
que c'est aussi de leur responsabilité
de garder leur ville belle et donc s'ils
pourraient très bien l'utiliser de
manière utile effectivement de pour que
ce patrimoine servent à quelque chose
c'est toujours possible et donc de le
restaurer mais ça ça leur fait peur ils
pensent qu'ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas
envie en fait
on l'a compris conserver un monument
historique est souvent un véritable
casse-tête à Châteaudun en Eure-et-Loir
la municipalité en possède beaucoup trop
pour une petite ville de 13000 habitants
alors en septembre dernier elle a vendu
une pièce maîtresse l'Hôtel-Dieu à une
célébrité du petit écran l'homme
d'affaires et animateur Julien Cohen
on est vraiment dans le dans le dur je
suis un amoureux de la pierre j'ai
acheté mon premier monument historique à
26 ans sans un sou et depuis voilà
j'enchaîne j'enchaîne les beaux ouvrages
on a le plus beau pays au monde avec un
patrimoine colossal patrimoine qu'on
ignore quelques fois et que les
habitants de Châteaudun semblent avoir
ignoré aussi de temps en temps
[Musique]
80 000 euros
ça Cohen trop bas pour l'opposition
municipale qui a déposé un recours
devant le tribunal administratif mais le
maire a des arguments
beaucoup se disent même tu aurais pu
vendre un euro symbolique et je préfère
le revoir revivre et moi je rappelle que
l'Hôtel-Dieu nous coûtait 46 000 euros
par an tous les coups compris le gaz le
chauffage électricité la tonte de
pelouse etc 46000 euros par an 10 ans on
est quasiment à 500.000 euros 500 000
euros en disant c'est beaucoup d'argent
pour pas faire grand-chose
quant à Julien Cohen il met en avant les
coups engendrés par les travaux pour
transformer cette énorme bâtisse en
maison des brocanteurs au
rez-de-chaussée et en hôtellerie dans
les étages supérieurs
sur la partie rez-de-chaussée on est
déjà à plus d'un million et demi alors
que on a fait on a fait des travaux qui
ne sont pas des travaux d'habitation qui
sont des travaux pour du commerce donc
on a recouvert les murs de bois c'est un
peu comme Disneyland il y a un peu de
maquillage mais c'est intelligemment
fait donc c'est propre et dans les
règles de l'art parce que les règles de
l'art en la matière de monuments
historique ne coûte très très cher
sachez qu'ici il y a 155 fenêtres qu'il
faut les changer on a on va aller sur du
double vitrage enchaîne massif avec des
crémone anciennes bref ça coûte les yeux
de la tête
l'ouverture au public est prévue cet été
et des brocantes seront organisées
chaque dernier dimanche du mois attirant
une nouvelle clientèle pour la ville on
va avoir des centaines d'emplois créés
d'ici trois quatre ans dans le
territoire en s'en réjouit et il faut
après dynamique patrimoniale et
touristique et tu peux l'avoir qu'avec
des porteurs de projets privés quand de
l'argent que nous on a pas et qui ont
aussi une dynamique une force
d'attraction Julien Cohen et en le
remercie vivement à une force
d'attraction colossale encore une fois
de France et on en a besoin on attire
avec Julien coin une très bonne image
une image très positive
vous pouvez une nouvelle fonction au
monument historique
de les conserver un élément patrimonial
ne doit pas être considéré comme une
chose
figée pour l'éternité dans un état donné
elle doit pouvoir accompagner la vie des
citoyens et être réutilisés
dans un dans certaines limites avec
certains certains niveaux d'exigence
mais elle doit pouvoir continuer à vivre
et être réutiliser et c'est dans ce sens
là que le patrimoine est un levier du
développement humain citoyen et
économique
pour les communes il n'est pas toujours
envisageable de vendre au privé et
lorsqu'on a pas de Julien Cohen dans son
carnet d'adresses il faut faire
fonctionner son imagination
à Levroux petit village du Berry les
travaux se terminent sur la porte de
champagne un édifice du 15e siècle qui
protégeait les habitants des attaques
extérieures les travaux ont été financés
en partie par des subventions publiques
et pour le reste la municipalité a eu
une idée plutôt originale faire
parrainer les tuiles à partir de 5 euros
le jour où on a fait la vente des tuiles
avec la signature par les habitants dans
la vendu plus de 700 en une seule
matinée et voyez le monde qu'il y avait
on avait on avait tendu un grand tapis
rouge le long de la porte de champagne
et donc le tapis était bondé de monde
donc là vous voyez c'est toutes les
tuiles qui ont été vendues signées pour
pour laisser une trace au sein de du
monument du monument historique alors il
y a des familles entières consignées
avec des tuiles pour le mari les enfants
les petits-enfants les arrières
petits-enfants enfin c'était vraiment un
bon rendez-vous familial
bonjour ça va très bien
avec plaisir je vous précède et 4 étages
plus haut la toiture de la porte de
champagne révèle tous ses secrets
c'est toujours beau quand on arrive ici
voilà vous voyez
voilà
les personnes donc ont signé les tuiles
au crayon bien évidemment au crayon en
mettant leurs noms de la date etc ou
leurs initiales et donc chaque étude
donc a été signée et stocker après
signature lorsqu'elle a engagé
l'opération de couverture quand les amis
en place régulièrement donc selon le
monument
après 4 ans de travaux tout le monde est
impatient de voir revivre le bâtiment
tous les corps de métiers sont là
charpentiers couvreur menuisier et maçon
bien sûr et ce qu'ils en font
aujourd'hui comme on la devine c'est
formidable moi j'ai qu'une envie c'est
que l'échafaudage tombe et qu'on
retrouve la splendeur de cette porte
médiévale à l'oeuvre
lorsque l'on visite un monument
et souvenir mais ici c'est l'oeuvre qui
se souvient des donateurs c'est là tout
l'intérêt s'approprier un petit morceau
de patrimoine pour laisser son empreinte
dans l'histoire